hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty science
chemistry phd skin care nerd and cranky old lady
today i'm going to be talking about products i
hate honestly it isn't even the product most of
the time it's just the marketing around it that
i hate if you like nerding out about the science
behind beauty products click the subscribe and the
nerdification bell so you don't miss any videos
let's start with coffee scrubs coffee scrubs are
usually a mix of oil and coffee grounds and coffee
grounds are the things that you have left over
after you've made coffee so you grind the coffee
soak it in water all the water comes out and
becomes your coffee and then you're left with
gunk and that gunk is what's in your coffee scrub
so instead of putting it in the garbage where it
belongs they put it in a bag with preservatives
and then sell it back to you for about 20 bucks
it's basically really expensive diy skincare the
way that most of these coffee scrub companies
convince people to still buy their product is
pretty much false advertising most of the time
there are all these claims that they get rid of
cellulite stretch marks and scars caffeine can
reduce the appearance of cellulite but not really
in the form of coffee scrubs based on the studies
on leave on caffeine creams and cellulite you
would need to have 2.1 kilograms of coffee grounds
left on your legs for hours there's no evidence
for caffeine helping with stretch muscle scars
massage can help but you can massage with
anything so any improvements that you see
with a coffee scrub are probably a combination
of massage exfoliation and good old placebo
you're seeing what you think you should be
seeing and really this shouldn't cost that much
there's also the fact that coffee scrubs are
really messy they tend to leave black bits in
your shower because they don't dissolve and
so you have to scrub yourself and then scrub
your shower which to me is just an awful lot of
scrubbing there's also the fact that cellulite is
a perfectly normal part of a woman's body most
women have it and there's nothing wrong with
having it it's not like some sort of pathology so
i feel like these companies sometimes overstep the
idea that you should be scrubbing these away
i think is quite damaging so instead if you do
want to reduce the appearance of cellulite i would
recommend getting a proper caffeine cream if you
want exfoliation without the mess i'd recommend
getting a sugar or salt scrub you can even mix
your own by putting oil in some sugar or some
salt and that would be a lot more cost effective
the next type of product is anti-blue light
products that are designed to protect you from
screens if you've seen my videos on visible light
damage and blue light you'll know why these are BS
blue light can have effects on skin in in vitro
studies on skin cells it's been found that blue
light can cause skin cells to produce more free
radicals and this could theoretically lead to
faster skin aging but this hasn't been tested
in clinical trials and skin cells in a petri
dish are very different from skin cells in skin
clinical studies have also found that darker skin
can develop hyperpigmentation with blue light but
the amount that comes from screens is really tiny
compared to the amounts used in studies the only
people who need to be concerned about the tiny
amounts of light coming from screens are people
with photosensitivity conditions you would know
if you have one of these conditions because your
doctor would have told you to be really careful
about turning on lights inside your house you
would need to sit in front of your screen for
days or months to get the same amount of visible
light that you'd get from 15 minutes of sunshine
this sounds kind of scary because we all know
that the sun causes skin damage it leads to
cancer and accelerated skin aging but the reason
we're scared of the sun is uv not visible light
visible light from the sun hasn't been linked
to skin cancer or aging so there's no reason why
brands who are selling anti-blue light products
should be focusing on screens rather than the sun
but most of them are and so like a lot of other
fear-mongering marketing i think they're really
trying to tap into and exploit our bias towards
natural things we like to think that things
that are natural like the sun are okay but things
that are artificial like screens and the internet
are bad for us in some way even though especially
during this pandemic screens have been really good
they've been helping a lot of us keep socially
connected and able to earn income while staying
safe but a lot of brands have been coming out
with these products during lockdown and i think
it's really just shady and opportunistic a more
likely way that blue light from screens might
be messing with your skin is by messing up your
sleep schedule there's some evidence that blue
light can suppress melatonin which is a hormone
that makes you sleepy but you can fix this with
a blue light filter app a lot of these are free
and you wouldn't fix this with a skin care product
jade rollers and gua sha tools now facial massage
is really nice and soothing it can help you relax
tight muscles it can also push out lymphatic
fluid and that can make your face look more toned
it's also good for a cooling effect and
i personally actually quite enjoy using
these massage tools the problem again is the
marketing it really tends to oversell the benefits
so you have claims like massaging your face can
increase your blood circulation this lets your
skin release toxins and calms inflammation it can
get rid of wrinkles stimulate collagen production
reduce cell turnover time minimize enlarged
pores boost elastin minimize spots caused by
toxin build up and it can reduce sagging now
theoretically improving your circulation could
possibly lead to increased collagen production but
this has never been shown it's a bit like claiming
that because fast food gives you energy and energy
makes you run faster eating lots of fast food
would make you a really good athlete there's a
theoretical mechanism but without more solid data
you can't make this sort of claim i think these
tools also rely a lot on exoticism to sell so
this is the whole ancient chinese secret sort of
marketing i don't think it's a coincidence that
jade rollers in particular really took off and
that gua sha tools took off rather than facial
massage stones there's also a lot of crystal
pseudoscience involved so there's a brand that
claims that rose quartz is an emotional healer
and that reduces and releases impurities and
stress and skin really good for detoxing and
somehow this emotional healer also helps you with
fine lines and wrinkles amethysts are meant to
be good for calming inflammation and acne red
jasper is a stone of vibrancy and endurance and
therefore it's good for hyperpigmentation now i
think this crystal stuff is a relatively harmless
pseudoscience but it still has some harms medical
pseudoscience with healing claims can lead people
to delay treatment for their medical conditions
and that can mean that it's a lot harder to treat
there are also serious issues with how crystals
are sourced a lot of them come from mines where
the workers have really bad conditions in a lot of
these places there's a lack of regulations which
means there's things like child labour and people
getting serious injuries while mining these rocks
and of course a lot of these workers aren't being
fairly paid i've put a link in the description
to an article where you can read more about this
spf drops so spf sunscreen drops are products
that you're meant to mix into other products
to basically turn it into a sunscreen so
you don't have to use a regular sunscreen
sunscreens don't always have good textures
and they break a lot of people out like me
and so this is a really appealing product but
like a lot of other really appealing ideas it
doesn't work sunscreen drops say they have high
spf but this is for the product on its own not
after you've mixed a few drops into something
else mixing a few drops into your foundation or
moisturizer means you're going to be diluting
it quite a lot as i've mentioned before if you
dilute a sunscreen it becomes way less effective
protection scales pretty much linearly so if you
dilute it by half you get half the spf three drops
is about 0.15 mL so that means on my face it would
give me an spf of somewhere between 5 and 10. now
theoretically you could apply them like a regular
sunscreen and get the proper amount of protection
but everything about the product encourages you to
only apply a few drops the fact that it comes
in a dropper bottle the instructions the fact
that it's a tiny bottle the fact that it's an
expensive bottle now even if we had a really high
protection product let's say spf 500 drops it's
still not a good idea to mix products yourself
to try to make a sunscreen that's because how well
a sunscreen works isn't just about how much active
ingredient you have it's also about how that
active ingredient is spread out there are a lot
of things that can impact this so what the other
ingredients in your mixed product are whether or
not they interact with each other how it spreads
over your skin and how it dries and this is why
sunscreen is one of the hardest products to
formulate so there's a whole bunch of variables
that this mixing doesn't take into account there's
also the fact that if you're mixing these drops
together you're probably not mixing them evenly
you also can't predict how these two products
will interact with each other when you mix them
so if you think about products balling up or
foundation separating so you're probably getting
patchy protection with this sort of spf mix
where some parts of your skin aren't getting
enough protection but i guess you're probably
only getting about spf 5 so maybe it doesn't
even matter you're probably better off using
a foundation with spf and we all know that that
isn't enough just use a proper dedicated sunscreen
so maybe i'm being a little bit harsh because
the products themselves aren't necessarily bad
it's just how you're meant to use them and how
they're marketed which i think are really bad i
don't know are you also really annoyed about
these products leave me a comment letting me
know and if you have other products that you
also hate click the thumbs up and subscribe it
really helps my videos on the algorithm
you can also follow me on instagram and
you can check out my blog for more beauty
science see you next time to nerd out more